earlier today I was at the Supreme Court
for the oral argument in Arizona versus
United States this is the case stemming
out of Arizona's controversial
anti-immigration law sb1070 now this law
has been in the news mostly due to fears
of racial profiling that would follow
from the law because one of the
provisions in the law allows the police
in fact instructs the police if they
have what's called a reasonable
suspicion to suspect that anyone who
they encounter in a stop arrest or
detain Minh may be in the country
illegally to then determine that
person's immigration status and so the
concern is a salute to racial profiling
so it's been in the news for these
controversial reasons but in fact what
was at issue today was not the racial
profiling question not a civil rights
question but a question known as a
preemption is Arizona just simply
following federal law enforcing it or AZ
Arizona intruding upon an area of
responsibility that solely belongs to
the federal government or is at the
discretion of the federal government in
certain ways it was a it was kind of a
replay of the big health care arguments
and one of the one of the main reasons
for that is you have the two protagonist
from that case squaring off again so
once again you have representing the
federal government Solicitor General
Donald Verrilli and this time
representing Arizona is Paul Clemente
the former Solicitor General and he was
representing the multi-state challengers
to the health care law so you have these
two very powerful attorneys in the
courtroom once again another interesting
repeat from the health care arguments a
few weeks ago is that the Solicitor
General he he had some moments where he
stumbled a bit before the justices he
got tangled up in some of his answers
and at one point this I thought was
quite interesting justice Sotomayor
interrupted and say listen I'm terribly
confused by what you're saying and that
was kind of an interesting rebuke and
then later in the argument she did
something similar where she said to him
you know social general listen you know
my colleagues get clearly my colleagues
are not buying what you're selling why
don't you try a different argument and
that's that's a kind of an unusual
rebuke and she's clearly on his side and
so one way to read that is is that you
know she she would like she thinks his
arguments are stronger she'd like the
federal government to prevail and she's
not entirely happy with the the advocacy
that's happening by the Solicitor
General so that that was a pretty pretty
noteworthy instance Arizona's biggest
supporter in court today was Justice
Scalia by far he he kind of openly
mocked the Solicitor General daph you
points the Solicitor General raised the
issue of foreign relations if Arizona is
just locking up everyone's suspected of
being illegal illegally in the state are
in the country and the federal
government is decided they don't
necessarily want to do that for nations
who we have various relationships with
could be upset about this Scalia openly
mocks this ideas as you know should are
you saying that the federal government
immigration policy should be based on
what makes Mexico happy you know it's
got some laughter in the courtroom
that's also got some uncomfortable kind
of shifting around I mean Scalia was was
quite hostile I think to what the
federal government was saying Arizona I
think in the future is very likely to
face civil rights civil liberties
challenges to the slaw I think this law
will in fact lead to credible
allegations of racial profiling of
harassment and other police abuses and
and those those challenges I think would
would stand a very good chance of
success in the courts the federal
government's argument is on shaky er
grounds I think and that's because
primarily the government may be serving
too much power in this instance so it's
not that the Arizona law is somehow
great but it's the federal government is
saying that you know we have the power
to stomp out all of these state
experiments and immigration law
enforcement and that I think what the
Supreme Court is going to say is that as
long as there's not a direct conflict
which federal government did not do a
very good job of pointing to today the
Arizona law gets to stand under the
preemption doctrine
I